Mày từ khi mở bán, những tâm vẽ tham dự, Trung cát đấu trường dành vọng mọi đông
hai ngàn không trăm mấy lâm, đã trả thành tập điểm chủ ý của cộp đồng yêu e Sport.
Và đến thời điểm này, con mộn số lượng vẽ tại Hanoi đã chính thức thế hàng.
Điều này thể hiện sự hấp tấn không thể phụ nhận, của dài đầu lươi quan mô bay hấp dẫn như trong nước.
Đừng ngày mong tâm đến ngày 12 tham mười, só lối chuyện mang tê xa còn trái tâm FBT Flash,
1st of e Sport, Box Gaming, Supernova, and TDD sẽ bất bảo tần thí đấu supa week với sự gồm vũ chỉ kết từ khách rà.
Nếu là rất là mặt lẽ để tìm ra bố đe kết tên xúc sắc nhất, rất cình và bỏng play off.
Các tên đủ sẽ phải thể hiện bản lính, năng lực và khi rằng thí đấu, chết hàng chậm về hấp mộn,
đoạn tạm lên những sạm cộm bộn bộn và đe cậm xuống.
Khá tông tin, đứa bán tổ chức, tọn mộn vài trung gết đấu trường dành bỏ hộn hành ý không cho mấy lâm đã được bản thêm trong thế giành hắn.